I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so cold. up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家心理健康服务机构担任助理临床医生。在申请临床心理学培训期间，我买了并阅读了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）作为陪伴。事实证明，它确实是很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在人们的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要太执着于最终目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所从事的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都意义重大。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对我来说很重要，因为我走过一段曲折的道路，并非进入该行业的典型路线。我衷心
recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down we often hand kids a phone and just hope for the best but what if that device is more like inviting an extra person into the family and a risky one at that in this episode I'm joined by Dr Marta de Roscajado to talk about her brand new book the smartphone solution our chat today is packed full of great tips and advice about how to introduce smartphones mindfully to set boundaries that actually work and even think about our own relationship with our screen time too. Whether you're a parent,
推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，请做好准备，暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下。我们经常给孩子一部手机，然后祈祷一切顺利，但如果那个设备更像是邀请了一个额外的人进入家庭，而且还是一个有风险的人呢？在这一集中，我邀请了玛尔塔·德·罗斯卡哈多（Dr. Marta de Roscajado）博士来谈谈她的新书《智能手机解决方案》（The Smartphone Solution）。我们今天的聊天充满了很棒的技巧和建议，关于如何有意识地引入智能手机，设定真正有效的界限，甚至思考我们自己与屏幕时间的关系。无论你是家长、
a teacher, working in mental health or just someone who feels like their phone is running the show, this conversation will help you take back control. I hope you find it really useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Just want to welcome along to the podcast Dr Marta DeRos Coirado. Hi. Hi. Thanks for being here and today we're talking about a very exciting thing which is happening, which is the publication of your second book, which is about kind of mindful introduction of phones and kind of technology for children and young people, isn't it? Yes, it's called The Smartphone Solution. And for me, it's a reassuring toolkit for parents. I think smartphones are such a hot topic at the moment. I think there's a lot of fear messaging
老师，从事心理健康工作，还是仅仅觉得手机在掌控你生活的人，这次谈话都将帮助你夺回控制权。希望你觉得它非常有用，如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。我想欢迎玛尔塔·德·罗斯·科伊拉多（Dr. Marta DeRos Coirado）博士来到播客。你好。你好。谢谢你来到这里，今天我们要谈论一件非常令人兴奋的事情，那就是你的第二本书出版了，它是关于为儿童和年轻人有意识地引入手机和技术，对吧？是的，它叫《智能手机解决方案》。对我来说，它是给家长的一套令人安心的工具包。我认为智能手机目前是一个非常热门的话题。我认为有很多恐惧信息
around smartphones. And for me, fear isn't the best place to begin making like good choices in any kind of situation. So I want to help parents have some awareness of the science and of what the good bits about smartphones as well as the things that are risks and maybe harmful to and give them a toolkit to support themselves and building healthier habits with their smartphones, but also being able to delay smartphones for younger children in a way that's really effective. And if you've got an older children who already has a smartphone, teach them how to use it in a way that's safe and healthy. So we're not consumed by smartphone use, but instead they're tools that we use because they're useful. Yeah, such important messaging.
围绕着智能手机。对我来说，恐惧并不是在任何情况下做出正确选择的最佳起点。所以我想帮助家长们对科学有所了解，了解智能手机的好处以及风险和可能有害的地方，并给他们一个工具包来支持自己，建立更健康的智能手机习惯，同时也能够以非常有效的方式为年幼的孩子推迟使用智能手机。如果你有已经拥有智能手机的大孩子，教他们以安全和健康的方式使用它。这样我们就不会被智能手机的使用所消耗，相反，它们是我们使用的工具，因为它们很有用。是的，非常重要的信息。
And it's actually about being more mindful about that, isn't it? And I watched your show, well done on your Channel 4 show as well, which was about that, the Great British Phone Swap, I think it was called, wasn't it? And it was just, I think it really showed me, like, how much scrolling people can do. And it's just as a way of almost killing time. It's not always as socially connected as we might think that it is. And it's, I really love the tip that you gave. It was like, tell someone what you're doing when you pick up your phone.
而且这实际上是关于对此更加有意识，不是吗？我看了你的节目，祝贺你在第四频道（Channel 4）的节目，也是关于这个的，叫《英国手机大交换》（The Great British Phone Swap），我想是这个名字吧？它真的向我展示了人们可以进行多少滚动浏览。这几乎是一种消磨时间的方式。它并不总是像我们想象的那样具有社交联系。而且，我真的很喜欢你给出的建议。就像是，当你拿起手机时，告诉别人你在做什么。
and then you're more likely to kind of only do that? It's one of those things that we do, again, without thinking. And I think most of us who own a smartphone now were never taught how to use it well. We might have learned how to use a particular app or, you know, something inside our phone. But we weren't taught about, you know, good behaviours, not so great behaviours. And we pick up our phones, I think, the way that we pick up a novel. We read them in silence. and they actually disrupt day-to-day interactions, day-to-day connections.
然后你更有可能只做那件事？这是我们不假思索就会做的那些事情之一。我认为我们大多数现在拥有智能手机的人从未被教导如何很好地使用它。我们可能学会了如何使用特定的应用程序，或者手机里的某些东西。但我们没有被教导关于好的行为，不太好的行为。我认为我们拿起手机的方式就像我们拿起小说一样。我们静静地阅读它们。而它们实际上扰乱了日常互动，日常联系。
We call it technopference, which is, I love that word because it makes so much sense to me, you know, technology interference. But, I mean, we know that it disrupts connection. I mean, within, like, the scrolling is something that just happens because it's so engaging and so distracting. And maybe you're distracting from an emotion. Maybe you're distracting from boredom. Maybe you're procrastinating. Maybe you're actually intentionally going online to do something.
我们称之为“技术干扰”（technopference），我喜欢这个词，因为它对我来说很有意义，你知道，技术干扰。但是，我的意思是，我们知道它会扰乱联系。我的意思是，滚动浏览是因为它太吸引人、太分散注意力而自然发生的。也许你在逃避某种情绪。也许你在逃避无聊。也许你在拖延。也许你实际上是有意上网去做某事。
But as soon as you start to scroll mindlessly, you might lose half an hour, maybe an hour. And, you know, there's some kind of data saying something like five hours on your phone over the course of your life is something like 25 years of your time. And that kind of data has stayed with me because I just think, oh my God, imagine what you could do in 25 years. and for me it's it's not about thinking that everything you do on your smoke phone is bad or useless but it's about really being very intentional about what you do so that there's times where you're not holding your phone you haven't got it on you you're not scrolling mindlessly you've got your phone somewhere else so you can actually be be with somebody or be with the TV even or you know just be with yourself or just look around you know like there's so many things that i feel like we
但一旦你开始无意识地滚动，你可能会浪费半小时，甚至一小时。而且，你知道，有一些数据说你一生中在手机上花费的五小时大约相当于你25年的时间。那种数据一直留在我的脑海里，因为我只是想，天哪，想象一下你在25年里能做些什么。对我来说，这并不是认为你在智能手机上做的每一件事都是坏的或无用的，而是关于非常刻意地去做你所做的事情，这样就有一些时间你没有拿着手机，你身上没有它，你没有无意识地滚动，你把手机放在别处，这样你就可以真正地和某人在一起，或者和电视在一起，或者你知道，只是和自己在一起，或者只是环顾四周，你知道，我觉得我们错过了很多东西，因为
miss because phones are really good at training us to check on them all the time and we don't have to like we can just be like okay you don't have to distract me i've got control over you because we do so that's one of the things i want to kind of help people understand that we've got control we are empowered as parents to take control of the habits that our children build with all technology but particularly smartphones. And I really think it does begin with us, kind of re-learning, unlearning some bits, re-learning some new bits, and embedding healthy habits in our home. So it becomes normal rather than something you've got to be like, I need to think about putting my phone down. Actually, if you just embed it in ways that are actually much simpler than you think,
手机非常擅长训练我们一直去查看它们，而我们不必这样做。我们可以只是说，好吧，你不需要分散我的注意力，我有对你的控制权，因为我们确实有。所以这是我想帮助人们理解的事情之一，我们有控制权，作为家长，我们有权控制我们的孩子与所有技术建立的习惯，特别是智能手机。我真的认为这确实始于我们，重新学习，摒弃一些旧习惯，重新学习一些新习惯，并将健康的习惯融入我们的家庭。这样它就变得正常了，而不是那种你需要像“我需要考虑放下手机”的事情。实际上，如果你只是以比你想象的简单得多的方式将其融入，
you might not have to think about it anymore. It just becomes a habit. Yeah, and I think I am naturally a bit more bounded about my phone. I am quite an annoying friend, but I'm happy to be so, because I don't have notifications set up for my WhatsApp. So I pick it up when I have a free moment and where I can choose whether to respond or not respond, but it means that I will suddenly have a flurry of activity on a chat thread, like responding, responding, responding, but then you won't hear from me for hours. People know if you want me, you've got to call me or actually text me because I won't see it otherwise because I don't have no certifications.
你可能就不需要再考虑它了。它就变成了一种习惯。是的，我认为我天生对手机更有界限感。我是一个相当烦人的朋友，但我很高兴如此，因为我没有为我的WhatsApp设置通知。所以我会在有空的时候拿起它，我可以选择是否回复，但这确实意味着我会在聊天线程中突然出现一阵活动，比如回复、回复、回复，但之后你几个小时都不会听到我的消息。人们知道如果你想找我，你必须给我打电话或者发短信，否则我不会看到，因为我没有通知。
And I think peer pressure is a big one, isn't it, for for kids, you know, for like Snapchat, for WhatsApp, for TikTok, like the FOMO and the, you know, the missing out on being in the moment. But I guess the message we want is it's okay. It's okay to do that. It's okay to miss out 100%. And it's also important to teach our children that thing you've learned, actually, Marianne, is not something lots of adults have learned, right? That kind of overwhelmed from WhatsApp in particular, group messaging, whatever chat you're using, the group messaging kind of, I don't know, culture, because it exists and we're all on it, is something we should be teaching our children. So this is a little story, and I've shared it a few times because it's really stayed with me, but I could share a thousand different ones. A young girl, that's 13, came to see me in clinic, and she was overwhelmed with anxiety,
而且我认为同伴压力是一个很大的因素，不是吗，对于孩子们来说，你知道，比如Snapchat，WhatsApp，TikTok，那种错失恐惧症（FOMO），以及那种错失当下的感觉。但我猜我们想要传达的信息是，没关系。这样做没关系。错过也没关系。100%。而且教我们的孩子你学到的那件事也很重要，实际上，玛丽安，这不是很多成年人都学到的，对吧？那种来自WhatsApp的压倒性感觉，特别是群聊，无论你使用什么聊天工具，群聊的那种，我不知道，文化，因为它存在，我们都在上面，是我们应该教给孩子的东西。所以这是一个小故事，我分享过几次，因为它真的留在了我的脑海里，但我可以分享一千个不同的故事。一个13岁的年轻女孩来我的诊所看我，她被焦虑所困扰，
which wasn't about her phone, just so we're clear. There were lots of things happening in her life. So the work, the core of our work was around anxiety, building coping tools, and also kind of learning to be with the feeling rather than avoid it or reject it. But part of the work that happened was that she had a phone, she had a smartphone, she probably still does, but her parents were really quite bounderied with it. And in the evening, they were very clear that she had to hand it in at 7 o'clock. And then she got it back in the morning. But in the morning, she told me, every morning she had over 200 messages pop up.
这与她的手机无关，我们要明确这一点。她的生活中发生了很多事情。所以工作的核心是关于焦虑，建立应对工具，以及学习与这种感觉共处，而不是逃避或拒绝它。但工作的一部分是她有一部手机，她有一部智能手机，她可能现在还有，但她的父母对它非常有界限感。在晚上，他们非常明确地要求她在7点钟上交。然后她在早上拿回它。但在早上，她告诉我，每天早上她都有超过200条消息弹出。
And she did not want to go to school without reading every single one of them. For the reason you've just said, I don't want to mention. out, like to her missing out was such a huge sense of anxiety. But, you know, if we really think about this, she's 13. How is that okay to be living with anxiety from other places? You know, anxiety is just part of life. We shouldn't be afraid of it. You know, I really feel like we need to learn to live with. But yes, anxiety can be overwhelming and stop us from functioning. And if one of the things that's stopping us from functioning well or stopping your child functioning well is social anxiety coming through a smartphone. We need to shift that. Now, for me, the solution
而且她不想在不阅读每一条消息的情况下就去上学。出于你刚才说的原因，我不想错过。对她来说，错过是一种巨大的焦虑感。但是，你知道，如果我们真的思考这个问题，她才13岁。生活在来自其他地方的焦虑中怎么会没问题呢？你知道，焦虑只是生活的一部分。我们不应该害怕它。你知道，我真的觉得我们需要学会与它共存。但是是的，焦虑可能是压倒性的，阻止我们正常运作。如果阻止我们正常运作或阻止你的孩子正常运作的事情之一是通过智能手机传来的社交焦虑。我们需要改变这一点。现在，对我来说，解决方案
with this young lady wasn't get rid of your phone, which it could be. There are alternatives, which I think are better, healthier, safer until children learn, you know, skills that are going to keep them safer online and accessing unfiltered internet, for example, which are, for me, mobile phones. I don't like calling them dumb phones or brick phones. They're just, mobile phones are great. So I don't want to dump them down. I don't know why we do that. They're not worse than a smartphone. They're different. They have a, you know, they actually do the role that you're talking about. They connect. You can text, you can call, you can take photos, you can still socialize with your friends, but they don't allow group chats and they don't allow unfiltered access to the internet.
对于这位年轻女士来说，并不是“扔掉你的手机”，虽然这也可以。有替代方案，我认为它们更好、更健康、更安全，直到孩子们学会了能让他们在网上更安全的技能，并访问未经过滤的互联网，例如，对我来说，就是移动电话。我不喜欢称它们为“笨手机”或“砖头手机”。它们只是，移动电话很棒。所以我不想贬低它们。我不知道为什么我们那样做。它们并不比智能手机差。它们只是不同。它们确实扮演了你正在谈论的角色。它们可以连接。你可以发短信，你可以打电话，你可以拍照，你仍然可以和你的朋友社交，但它们不允许群聊，也不允许对互联网进行未经过滤的访问。
And I think that's healthy. You can still teach your kid's responsibility using a phone and good digital habits and, you know, cyberbullity. There's so many things you can teach them with a phone. Anyway, this young girl kept her smartphone, but she chose to come off WhatsApp. That was her choice. But over the course of our work, she decided that WhatsApp was one of the things that was overwhelming her to the point where she couldn't do her homework anymore. because she was like, I've been running out of time to like read all the messages and in the morning I've got 200 more to read. I mean, that's not the way to socialize. So we need to help our
我认为这很健康。你仍然可以使用手机教孩子责任感和良好的数字习惯，以及网络欺凌。有很多事情你可以用手机教他们。无论如何，这个年轻女孩保留了她的智能手机，但她选择退出WhatsApp。那是她的选择。但在我们的工作过程中，她决定WhatsApp是让她感到不知所措的事情之一，以至于她无法再做家庭作业了。因为她觉得，我没时间阅读所有的消息，早上还有200条要读。我的意思是，那不是社交的方式。所以我们需要帮助我们的
children understand what is good socialization? What does that look like? What does it feel like? In person, first of all, you know, can we develop good social skills with people because they translate into the digital world 100%. And then we need to teach our children that when something doesn't feel good in the real world or online. You need to like pause, reflect and set up some boundaries because something isn't working. The same way that if you were always going to a friend's house and every time your child goes to that friend's house, they come out completely distressed, you'd be like, wait, wait, wait, wait, something's going on with this friend. We need to think about how you're feeling in relationship with this other child because something doesn't feel
孩子理解什么是好的社交？那看起来是什么样的？感觉如何？首先是面对面，你知道，我们能和人们发展良好的社交技能吗？因为它们可以100%转化为数字世界。然后我们需要教我们的孩子，当现实世界或网络上的某些事情感觉不好时。你需要暂停、反思并设定一些界限，因为有些事情行不通。就像如果你总是去朋友家，每次你的孩子去那个朋友家，他们出来时都完全心烦意乱，你会说，等等，等等，这个朋友出了点问题。我们需要考虑你在与这个孩子的关系中感觉如何，因为有些事情感觉
right. But that happens on our phones too. You know, kids are exposed to stuff that distresses them, that builds anxiety, that builds sadness, that builds anger in their bodies. And if they're not able to register it, because our brains do something very different when we're looking at tech than when we're looking at a person, the distance from the screen to another human means that we sometimes don't register what's happening in our bodies. And I really believe that, you know, that should be part of emotional regulation. That should be part of how, we teach our children, how do you feel when you come off your screen? How does it feel that you're giving me your phone? Like with this young girl, she felt, I can't go to sleep. Like,
不对。但这也会发生在我们的手机上。你知道，孩子们接触到让他们心烦意乱、产生焦虑、产生悲伤、在身体里产生愤怒的东西。如果他们不能意识到这一点，因为当我们在看技术时，我们的大脑与我们在看人时所做的事情非常不同。从屏幕到另一个人之间的距离意味着我们有时不会意识到我们的身体正在发生什么。我真的相信，你知道，那应该是情绪调节的一部分。那应该是我们教孩子的一部分，当你离开屏幕时你感觉如何？你把手机给我时感觉如何？就像这个年轻女孩，她觉得，我无法入睡。就像，
I know, I know that in the morning. I've got to, I mean, you know, just having that conversation with her parents was absolutely life-changing, I think, for them as a family, because the parents were like, we thought we were setting a boundary that was going to help her rest. But actually, she was stressing about all the messages that were going to appear before she even woke up. like that's not a way to rest that she was just like buzzing even though her phone was nowhere near her we need to understand that and be aware of it as parents so that we can adjust the boundaries have open conversations with our kids how can we allow our children to stay connected so she uses hopefully still does don't know um she might see this and message me um she uses
我知道，我知道在早上。我必须，我的意思是，你知道，仅仅与她的父母进行那次谈话，我认为对他们作为一个家庭来说是绝对改变生活的，因为父母们说，我们以为我们设定了一个能帮助她休息的界限。但实际上，她在醒来之前就一直在为所有将要出现的消息感到压力。就像那不是休息的方式，她只是像在嗡嗡作响，即使她的手机离她很远。我们需要理解这一点，并作为家长意识到这一点，以便我们可以调整界限，与我们的孩子进行开放的对话，我们如何才能让我们的孩子保持联系？所以她使用，希望现在还在用，不知道，嗯，她可能会看到这个并给我发消息，她使用
WhatsApp on her parents' laptop. So she still has communication with her friends, but when she closes it, she's like, I'm not looking at this in the morning. I do this and then I go away. And she's also very clear about that boundary with some of her friends. She's gone off all the big groups. WhatsApp is, I know you said yours is no notifications, which I think is great. Hers is like not on my phone. Like WhatsApp is something I do in a laptop, intentioning. I'm sent it out after school and I'm going to like chit-chat to particular friends, but I'm not in my class group, for example. She realized she didn't have to hear everything from every kid in her year. She was like, why am I doing that? And the truth is, loads of teenagers do it for that reason,
她父母笔记本电脑上的WhatsApp。所以她仍然与她的朋友保持联系，但当她关闭它时，她会说，我早上不会看这个。我做这个，然后我就走开。她对她的一些朋友也非常明确那个界限。她退出了所有的大群。WhatsApp是，我知道你说你的没有通知，我觉得这很好。她的是像不在我的手机上。就像WhatsApp是我在笔记本电脑上做的事情，是有意为之的。我放学后发出去，我要和特定的朋友聊天，但我不在我的班级群里，例如。她意识到她不必听到她那一年级每个孩子说的每一件事。她当时想，我为什么要那样做？事实是，很多青少年这样做就是因为那个原因，
the fear of losing out. And we need to like help them learn. That's not what good social interaction looks like. Yeah, absolutely. And I had a very similar experience in our house. So my eldest had a phone, a smartphone, my old smartphone. I think this is the tricky thing, is I didn't necessarily buy it for him, but I'd got rid of it because the battery, you know, iPhones, wasn't lasting. So I bought him a phone case charger thing, which then meant the battery was fine again. And I gave him that in kind of around half term, October half term, year six, because he'd started to go out by himself. So it was more as a tracking device. But actually, when he went to year he's just about to start year eight um one sunday afternoon i could just hear this buzzing buzzing buzzing buzzing
错失恐惧症。我们需要帮助他们学习。那不是好的社交互动看起来的样子。是的，绝对。我在家里也有过非常相似的经历。所以我的长子有一部手机，一部智能手机，我旧的智能手机。我认为这是棘手的事情，我并不一定是为了他买的，但我已经处理掉它了，因为电池，你知道，iPhone，不耐用了。所以我给他买了一个手机壳充电器，这意味着电池又好了。我在十月期中假左右，六年级时给了他，因为他开始自己出门了。所以它更多是作为一个追踪设备。但实际上，当他进入八年级，他正要开始八年级，嗯，一个周日下午，我能听到这种嗡嗡声，嗡嗡声，嗡嗡声，嗡嗡声，
and i realized it was his phone and like oh strange um he didn't have it with him i think he was at a piano lesson or something and during the space of about three hours i went and looked at his phone he had 1,157 WhatsApp notifications and it was just basically his year group just like spamming like just stupid stuff like and I think the difference with communication like if I sent you a message I would send it all in one go whereas often they'll send it line by lines that comes through as separate things separate buzzes separate notifications and I was like I think that's something adults don't all understand teenagers don't communicate online like we communicate online they do that sentence by sentence moment by moment also you know if you've got if you've got a smart
我意识到那是他的手机，就像，哦，奇怪，嗯，他没带在身上，我想他在上钢琴课还是什么的，在大约三个小时的时间里，我去看了他的手机，他有1,157条WhatsApp通知，基本上就是他的同年级组在像垃圾邮件一样，就像愚蠢的事情，我认为沟通的区别在于，如果我给你发消息，我会一次性发完，而他们通常会逐行发送，所以它作为单独的东西、单独的嗡嗡声、单独的通知传进来，我当时想，我认为这是成年人并不都理解的事情，青少年不像我们在线沟通那样在线沟通，他们是逐句、逐时刻地那样做。而且，你知道，如果你口袋里有一部智能
phone in your pocket, it's not the same as a tablet or a laptop because it's so readily accessible. So something happens or they see something, they'll pick it up, they take a photo, they send it to the grip, you know, like, it's that instant, it's that instant kind of messaging that really appeals to teenagers. Like, look, look what I'm seeing. It's like they're constantly talking to each other, right? They never have to be separate from each other, which I remember as an adolescent, you know, really wanting. I'd been all day at school with my friends and I'd come home and I would go straight on my landline and be like calling my best friend. I remember my mum saying, what on earth have you got to say to her? You've been at school with her all day and I was like
手机，它和iPad或笔记本电脑不一样，因为它太容易获取了。所以发生了什么事，或者他们看到了什么，他们就会拿起它，拍照，发给群组，你知道，就像，它是那种即时的，它是那种即时的消息传递，真的很吸引青少年。就像，看，看我看到了什么。就像他们一直在互相交谈，对吧？他们永远不必与彼此分开，我记得作为青少年，你知道，真的很想要。我整天在学校和朋友在一起，我回到家，我会直接用我的座机给最好的朋友打电话。我记得我妈妈说，你到底有什么要对她说的？你整天在学校和她在一起，我说
loads of stuff has happened. You know, like it's just what you do as a teenager. And I think as adults, we need to understand that that poll is going to be there and it's normal. It's part of development. But we need to help our children connect well with their friends rather than connect all the time. Because when we do it all the time, it becomes meaningless. It basically is like white noise. It's not meaningful interaction anymore. It's just buzz and stress. You know, it's sensory overwhelm is what I think it becomes. But it does, it's not meaningful anymore because you can't, you know, out of a thousand messages, which of those are the ones that your kid has to like use discernment to go, these are the important ones I'm going to hold and respond to. These
发生了好多事。你知道，就像这只是你作为青少年会做的事情。我认为作为成年人，我们需要理解那种吸引力会一直存在，这是正常的。这是发展的一部分。但我们需要帮助我们的孩子与他们的朋友建立良好的联系，而不是一直联系。因为当我们一直这样做时，它就变得毫无意义了。它基本上就像白噪音。它不再是有意义的互动了。它只是嗡嗡声和压力。你知道，我认为它变成了感官过载。但它确实，它不再有意义了，因为你不能，你知道，在一千条消息中，哪一条是你的孩子必须使用辨别力去判断的，这些是我要保留并回复的重要消息。这些
are all the ones I'm going to ignore. I mean, as an adult, I find that overwhelming, let alone being a teenager who wants to respond to every single one of those messages. It's really tough, and we need to teach our children how to connect well, which is why I wrote my book, because I think as adults, we've not been aware that this is what happens when we offer a children a hand-me-down. We're trying to support them in staying connected with us, like you said, you know, being contactable, being safe. It all makes so much sense. But I think being aware that actually a smartphone doesn't do all of that. It does that and it has the potential to overwhelm, to stress, to overstimulate, to not allow your child a break. Then you can start to think, how do we give them connection and socialization,
是我要忽略的所有消息。我的意思是，作为一个成年人，我发现这让人不知所措，更不用说作为一个想回复每一条消息的青少年了。这真的很艰难，我们需要教我们的孩子如何建立良好的联系，这就是我写书的原因，因为我认为作为成年人，我们没有意识到当我们给孩子一部旧手机时会发生什么。我们试图支持他们与我们保持联系，就像你说的，你知道，保持可联系，保持安全。这一切都很有道理。但我认为意识到实际上智能手机并不能做到所有这些。它做到了这一点，并且有潜力让人不知所措、产生压力、过度刺激、不允许你的孩子休息。然后你就可以开始思考，我们如何给他们联系和社交，
but in a way that feels more boundaries, that feels that may be safer as well, because the unfiltered internet is not safe. I mean, I'm not even sure it's safe for adults. let alone kids who are really impulsive and we'll see something and be like, oh, what's that? And suddenly they're like diving into something they weren't even looking for. Like that happens all the time. It's curiosity and they're really curious. So I think for me, the reason why I wrote my book was to build awareness about all of this,
但以一种感觉更有界限感的方式，感觉可能也更安全的方式，因为未经过滤的互联网是不安全的。我的意思是，我甚至不确定它对成年人是否安全，更不用说那些真的很冲动、会看到什么就说“哦，那是什么？”的孩子，突然间他们就像潜入了一些他们甚至没在寻找的东西。就像那一直都在发生。这是好奇心，他们真的很好奇。所以我认为对我来说，我写书的原因是为了建立对这一切的认识，
but really to give parents a toolkit because I don't think awareness on its own is often motivational enough. I think people get stuck in the fear, which is what we have at the moment. And I really wanted people to feel unstuck. I wanted people to feel like, okay, I've got a toolkit, and I can use it, and I can embed some of these ideas in my family home, not just for my kids, but for me to role model what this looks like and try it out. Like, for me, it's about doing it together.
但真正是为了给家长一个工具包，因为我不认为仅仅有意识通常就足够有动力了。我认为人们陷入了恐惧，这就是我们目前所拥有的。我真的希望人们感到不再被困住。我希望人们觉得，好吧，我有一个工具包，我可以使用它，我可以将其中一些想法融入我的家庭，不仅是为了我的孩子，也是为了我，去树立这看起来是什么样的榜样并尝试一下。就像，对我来说，这是关于一起做。
You and your child, you're on the same side, and smartphones are not your whole world, you know, your whole identity. They're just a tool. And, you know, even using them well for connection is something I don't think we're very good at because texts are the worst way to connect through a phone. Phone calls are so much better and video calls are even better. So I think if you have a smartphone, start video calling people or voice note people, which lots of people in my generation will not do. But it's so much better. It's the human essence of us.
你和你的孩子，你们在同一边，智能手机不是你的整个世界，你知道，你的整个身份。它们只是一个工具。而且，你知道，即使是很好地利用它们进行联系，我认为我们也不是很擅长，因为短信是通过手机联系的最糟糕的方式。电话要好得多，视频通话甚至更好。所以我认为如果你有智能手机，开始视频通话或语音留言，我这一代很多人不会这样做。但它好得多。它是我们的人性本质。
And that's what builds connection, not words on a text that have no tone. You can misread them. You know, I've met so many kids who are like, look, I mean, loads of the kids I work with, show me their phones, show me their texts. So much of their life happens online. But they'll show me a text, and the way I interpret it is so different from the way they interpret it. I don't know who's right, because it's a text. That's very different if you have a phone message or a voice note.
而那才是建立联系的东西，而不是没有语气的短信文字。你可能会误读它们。你知道，我见过很多孩子，他们就像，看，我的意思是，我合作的很多孩子，给我看他们的手机，给我看他们的短信。他们生活中的很多事情都在网上发生。但他们会给我看一条短信，我解读它的方式与他们解读它的方式非常不同。我不知道谁是对的，因为那是短信。如果你有电话留言或语音留言，那就非常不同了。
And that's something I'm learning, because I've started to voice note a lot more, especially when I have something meaningful to say. If I want to say something caring to my friend because she's having a really tough time, she's sick, you know, something's happened to my kids, I voice note. I want them to hear my voice. I want them to hear,
而那是我正在学习的东西，因为我已经开始更多地使用语音留言，特别是在我有话要说的时候。如果我想对我的朋友说些关怀的话，因为她正在经历一段非常艰难的时期，她生病了，你知道，我的孩子发生了什么事，我发语音留言。我希望他们听到我的声音。我希望他们听到，
and maybe we don't have to have, I don't have time for a two and for a conversation, which is what I think texting is about. I don't have time to call somebody. I just want to say something quickly, you know, I hope you're okay. Let me know how your kid is doing. you know i get it but if you do it on a voice note it actually shares a little bit of humanness
也许我们不必有，我没有时间进行来回的对话，我认为短信就是关于这个的。我没有时间给某人打电话。我只是想快速说点什么，你知道，我希望你没事。让我知道你的孩子怎么样。你知道，我明白了，但如果你用语音留言，它实际上分享了一点人性
that is totally lacking in a test and honestly since i've been doing it which is just before i started writing my book and definitely since um i've noticed something really interesting which is every single time every time my friends replying and say something like oh my god you made me really happy or i cried or and i've said like literally 30 second or maybe you're be a minute message. But it's because they hear my voice and they're like, it's like you're here with me. And I'm like, yeah, that's what we should be using of phones for to feel like we're in the presence of others who are far away from us, not to be overwhelmed by text messages or noise or, you know, distressing videos. Definitely. I love a voice note. Not everyone does, but I do. My husband
这在短信中是完全缺乏的，老实说，自从我开始这样做，也就是在我开始写书之前，绝对是在那之后，我注意到了一些非常有趣的事情，那就是每一次，每一次我的朋友回复并说类似“天哪，你让我真的很开心”或“我哭了”之类的话，而我说的只是字面上的30秒或可能是一分钟的消息。但这是因为他们听到了我的声音，他们就像，就像你和我在一起一样。我说，是的，这就是我们应该利用手机的地方，去感觉我们和远方的其他人在一起，而不是被短信或噪音或，你知道，令人心烦意乱的视频所淹没。绝对。我喜欢语音留言。不是每个人都喜欢，但我喜欢。我丈夫
was like, please, can you never leave me a voice note again? I'm like, okay. Why? Why did you say that? He doesn't like, because it takes me so long. It takes ages to listen. I was like, well, you can click transcribe if you must. I think that's so interesting. But I think that's just part of what's happening at the moment. There's this kind of speed in our society. Like, we're scared to slow down.
当时说，求你了，你能不能再也不给我留语音留言了？我说，好吧。为什么？你为什么那样说？他不喜欢，因为它花了我太长时间。听起来要花很长时间。我说，好吧，如果你必须的话，你可以点击转录。我觉得这太有趣了。但我认为这只是目前正在发生的事情的一部分。我们的社会有一种速度。就像，我们害怕慢下来。
Like, don't slow me down. I can't listen to your voice now. Or don't call me because I don't have time. I'm like, actually building healthy habits with technology might actually give a space and tame. which you don't even realize we're wasting when we're mindlessly scrolling and we think we're relaxing, but we're not, because if we actually notice what's happening in our bodies, a lot of a time, we're not more relaxed when we like put the phone out. We're more stressed because we've spent
就像，别让我慢下来。我现在听不到你的声音。或者别给我打电话，因为我没时间。我说，实际上建立健康的科技习惯可能实际上会给出一个空间和时间，而我们在无意识地滚动时甚至没有意识到我们在浪费它，我们以为我们在放松，但我们没有，因为如果我们真正注意到我们的身体正在发生什么，很多时候，当我们放下手机时，我们并没有更放松。我们更紧张，因为我们花了
too long on it or we've looked at content that isn't uplifting or isn't making us feel good. So, you know, I think, I mean, that is also in my book. I think learning to rest and teaching our children this is critically important. I mean, you know, we think about development. Development isn't just reading and writing and riding a bike. It's emotional. It's learning what does my body need? What does my brain need? What kind of social interaction makes me feel good? What kind of social interaction do I need a little bit lesser? Because actually, it's making me feel really bad by the time I get to bed. Those things matter. And I think if you've not learned them in childhood and you're then given a smartphone, I think it just disrupts all of it. I think it's
太长时间在上面，或者我们看了那些不令人振奋或不让我们感觉良好的内容。所以，你知道，我想，我的意思是，那也在我的书中。我认为学习休息并教我们的孩子这一点至关重要。我的意思是，你知道，我们思考发展。发展不仅仅是阅读、写作和骑自行车。它是情感上的。它是学习我的身体需要什么？我的大脑需要什么？什么样的社交互动让我感觉良好？什么样的社交互动我需要少一点？因为实际上，当我上床睡觉时，它让我感觉很糟糕。那些事情很重要。而且我认为如果你在童年时期没有学到它们，然后你又被给了一部智能手机，我认为它只是扰乱了这一切。我认为这
really tricky. And I think that's why lots of adults my age find the changing habits so challenging because they're so embedded now that it feels difficult. Do you think some of the slippery slope started with these unlimited contracts? So when I was learning to use a phone, I had to pay 12 p per text. You know, maybe you did as well. And you only had like, can't you? And you only had like a maximum of like 200 or 300 minutes that you could use and so you had to kind of meter your usage and you wouldn't just send something kind of you know vague or unrelated it was it was a method of connecting and communication but now you probably wouldn't dream of buying a phone contract that didn't have unlimited texts that didn't have unlimited minutes now it's the data that might
真的很棘手。而且我认为这就是为什么很多像我这个年纪的成年人发现改变习惯如此具有挑战性，因为它们现在已经根深蒂固，以至于感觉很困难。你认为一些滑坡是从这些无限合同开始的吗？所以当我学习使用手机时，我必须为每条短信支付12便士。你知道，也许你也一样。而且你只有像，不是吗？而且你只有像最多200或300分钟你可以使用，所以你必须以某种方式计量你的使用量，你不会只是发送一些，你知道，模糊或不相关的东西，它是一种联系和沟通的方法，但现在你可能做梦也不会想到购买一份没有无限短信、没有无限分钟的手机合同，现在是数据可能
be more capped and that's the thing that you might think about but you know i think definitely interesting thought. I've definitely picked up my phone more. I remember when my friend Nikki at uni, I think we'd left uni and she was one of the first ones to get like 500 text messages a month as part of her contract. And I thought, amazing, I'll hear from her all the time. Like, she's going to have so many messages. Like, but I didn't hear from her any more than I used to. And then when I got my own 500 contract, like I just, you know, I just started to use it more. in the way that I do now. And then I messages started
会被限制得更多，那是你可能会考虑的事情，但你知道，我认为绝对是一个有趣的想法。我绝对拿起手机的次数更多了。我记得当我的朋友尼基在大学时，我想我们已经离开大学了，她是第一批合同中每月有500条短信的人之一。我想，太棒了，我会一直听到她的消息。就像，她会有这么多消息。就像，但我听到她的消息并不比以前多。然后当我得到我自己的500条合同，就像我只是，你知道，我只是开始更多地使用它。以我现在的方式。然后我消息开始了
and then that doesn't even count towards your message date. Like, I think it's just, it's almost caught us, caught us unawares, I think. They gave us more of what they thought we wanted and maybe we never needed it to begin with. I think,
然后那甚至不计入你的消息日期。就像，我认为它只是，它几乎让我们措手不及，我想。他们给了我们更多他们认为我们想要的东西，也许我们一开始根本就不需要它。我想，
I think they give us more of what keeps us online for more and we need to be aware that that's what brings money to these companies, to these apps. The more time we spend online, the more money they make. fact. We're losing out. I mean, we're definitely losing out. We're losing out on time. We're losing out on our well-being. I really believe that. We're losing out on our presence. We're
我想他们给了我们更多让我们保持在线更久的东西，我们需要意识到这就是给这些公司、这些应用程序带来金钱的东西。我们在网上花费的时间越多，他们赚的钱就越多。事实。我们正在失去。我的意思是，我们绝对在失去。我们在失去时间。我们在失去我们的幸福。我真的相信这一点。我们在失去我们的存在。我们
losing out on the ability to just be. But they're gaining. Like, everything you're talking about makes complete sense to me. I hadn't thought about the unlimited stuff, but 100%. That's just, for me, that's just another trick to keep us online for longer. And I think it's about us. making a decision, right? We live in a consumerist society. And it's not just smartphones. There's lots of things that around us make us spend more money. You know, marketing is, that's what it's for, right? That's capitalism. That's what it is. So I think we need to be discerning and thoughtful about where, you know, we put, I mean, everyone I know works really hard to earn the money that they earn and we need to start to think where do I want to spend my money but also where do I want
在失去仅仅是“存在”的能力。但他们正在获得。就像，你谈论的一切对我来说都完全有意义。我没有想到无限的东西，但100%。对我来说，那只是另一个让我们保持在线更久的把戏。而且我认为这是关于我们。做出决定，对吧？我们生活在一个消费主义社会。而且不仅仅是智能手机。我们周围有很多东西让我们花更多的钱。你知道，营销是，这就是它的目的，对吧？那是资本主义。这就是它。所以我认为我们需要对我们在哪里，你知道，我们投入，我的意思是，我认识的每个人都非常努力地赚取他们赚的钱，我们需要开始思考我想把钱花在哪里，但也想把我的精力花在哪里
to put my energy I think we need to start putting value to our time and our energy when we're not at work in the same way that we do when we're at work because you know I often think about that with my kids I think about it's really confronting because it makes me emotional because I know I fall into this trap and it is in my book and I couch it in so much empathy because I know I do this too but you know our phones have definitely trained us to keep them on us and to keep checking them a bit like i think of it a bit like a pet or something you got to keep alive you know are you okay yeah you're fine are you okay the tamagotchi effect it's the tamagotchi a hundred percent and you know you said about your first phone i got we know how annoying those tamagotchis
我认为我们需要开始重视我们的时间和精力，当我们不在工作时，就像我们在工作时一样，因为你知道，我经常和我的孩子们想到这一点，我想它真的很令人面对，因为它让我情绪化，因为我知道我陷入了这个陷阱，它在我的书中，我用如此多的同理心来表达它，因为我知道我也这样做，但你知道，我们的手机绝对训练了我们把它们带在身上并不断查看它们，有点像，我想它有点像宠物或什么东西，你必须让它活着，你知道，你还好吗？是的，你很好，你还好吗？电子宠物效应，它是电子宠物，百分之百。而且你知道，你说了关于你的第一部手机，我们知道那些电子宠物有多烦人
were right i never had one because like didn't you they did they did themselves you, they needed feeding. They'd bleep at you in the middle of the night. I've seen them. I know. We've basically got tamagocches that we carry around constantly. 100%. I think about that all the time. Honestly, I think that's actually my analogy. But genuinely, it's that. A thousand percent. And I remember my first phone, I got it when I went to university. My parents bought it for me in like a Vodafone shop. It was like a brick. And I never took it with me. I left it in my room all the time. And I remember my mum going, every time I call you, you don't pick up. And I'm like, I don't carry it with me. You know, it was a mobile phone that
对吧？我从来没有过，因为像，你没有吗？它们确实，它们确实自己，它们需要喂养。它们会在半夜对你发出哔哔声。我见过它们。我知道。我们基本上带着我们不断随身携带的电子宠物。100%。我一直想到这一点。老实说，我认为那实际上是我的类比。但真正地，就是那样。一千个百分点。而且我记得我的第一部手机，我上大学时得到的。我父母在沃达丰（Vodafone）商店给我买的。它就像一块砖头。我从来没带它去过任何地方。我一直把它留在我的房间里。而且我记得我妈妈说，每次我给你打电话，你都不接。我说，我不随身携带它。你知道，它是一部移动电话，
was like a landline. And then as they got smaller, I moved from that. It was massive. It was an Erickson. I literally was the size of my head. It was so big. I moved from that to a tiny Nokia. I don't know if you remember them. And they used to fit in my denim jacket. So then I used to take it everywhere and that's where it started for me for sure that it fit on me and it had um it used to buzz you could put it on buzz which wasn't silent but rather than the you know rain did did dee or whatever it used to do it used to buzz at me and so I ended up always having it on me so I could feel it but not hear it I think that's a problem I think that's for me where it all began that kind of training the Tamagocchi training
就像座机一样。然后随着它们变小，我从那里搬走了。它很大。它是爱立信（Erickson）。我字面上是和我头一样大。它太大了。我从那里换成了一个小诺基亚。我不知道你是否记得它们。它们过去常装在我的牛仔夹克里。所以然后我开始随身携带它，那就是我开始的地方，肯定是因为它适合我，而且它有，嗯，它过去常嗡嗡作响，你可以把它调成嗡嗡声，那不是静音，而是，你知道，铃声，或者它过去常做的任何事情，它过去常对我嗡嗡作响，所以我最终总是把它带在身上，这样我就能感觉到它，但听不到它。我认为那是一个问题，我认为对我来说，那就是一切开始的地方，那种训练，电子宠物训练
of I'm buzzing so you need to care for me, you need to look, you need to stop whatever you're doing and go into this digital kind of world. I actually talk about thinking of your screen like a front door and every time you open it, you're going into another world because you're disengaging from whatever you're doing. And for me that's a really helpful metaphor that I use for myself because when I'm with other people and they pick up their phones and I'm talking to them it's so grating but we do it to all like I do it you probably do it you get it done to you and it's so offensive it's like it's like my toddler being like mama mama which she does all day I'm talking to your dad you know and I'm trying to teach our patience
我正在嗡嗡作响，所以你需要照顾我，你需要看，你需要停止你正在做的任何事情，进入这种数字世界。我实际上谈到了把你的屏幕想象成一扇前门，每次你打开它，你都在进入另一个世界，因为你正在脱离你正在做的任何事情。对我来说，那是一个非常有用的隐喻，我为自己使用，因为当我和其他人在一起，他们拿起手机，我正在和他们说话时，它太刺耳了，但我们都这样做，就像我这样做，你可能也这样做，你让它发生在你身上，这太冒犯了，就像，就像我的蹒跚学步的孩子说“妈妈，妈妈”，她整天都这样做，我正在和你爸爸说话，你知道，我正在试图教我们的耐心
right now you know hold my hand I'm just going to finish and I do it very quick I don't even really finish my sentence but I try and model that I'm having a conversation and now I turn to you. But we don't do that with our phones. We don't do that with our phones. They buzz. We just pick them up. Oh, sorry. No, I just wanted to see. No. Like, why? Why is that buzzing more important than this conversation we're having? Or more important than this essay you're writing or whatever, whatever you're doing, the film you're watching. Are you sure it's that important? Or is it just that you've been trained? And if you've been trained, you can untrain yourself. I think many of us have become less offended. I remember the
现在你知道了，握住我的手，我马上就说完，我做得很快。我甚至没有真正说完我的句子，但我试图表现出我正在进行对话，现在我转向你。但我们对手机却不是这样。我们对手机不是这样。它们震动，我们就拿起来。哦，抱歉。不，我只是想看看。不。为什么？为什么那个震动比我们正在进行的对话更重要？或者比你正在写的这篇文章，或者无论你在做什么，你正在看的电影更重要？你确定它那么重要吗？还是说你只是被训练成了这样？如果你是被训练出来的，你也可以进行反训练。我认为我们很多人已经变得不那么容易被冒犯了。我记得
first time I ever went out for dinner with one of my friends at the time. She's still my good friend, actually, Dr. Kara. And she put her phone on the table, probably wasn't the first time we've been out for dinner, but the first time this had happened. And I remember feeling a bit offended, like, are you going to get a better offer than what we're doing right now? Whereas now, it's so common that we will have our phone on the table, not for my family dinners, I don't do that for family dinners. We have a zero phone policy for family dinners. But it's so common when you go out for dinner at a restaurant
我第一次和当时的一位朋友出去吃晚餐。其实她现在还是我的好朋友，卡拉博士。她把手机放在桌子上，可能那不是我们第一次出去吃晚餐，但这是第一次发生这种情况。我记得当时感到有点被冒犯，心想，难道你会得到比我们现在正在做的事情更好的提议吗？而现在，把手机放在桌子上太常见了，当然我的家庭晚餐不会这样，我家庭晚餐不这样做。我们家庭晚餐有零手机政策。但当你去餐馆吃晚餐时，这太常见了
that you will have your phone on the table. And maybe we need to start being more offended by that again. I think it's just become normalized, hasn't it? It's just become like the status quo. And I think I don't know about getting more offended. I believe in communicating better with each other. Like, you know, and I give. scripts for this in my book because I think it's really easy to snap at somebody. And actually when
你会把手机放在桌子上。也许我们需要开始再次对此感到被冒犯。我认为这已经变得常态化了，不是吗？它已经变成了现状。而且我认为，我不知道是否要变得更容易被冒犯。我相信更好地相互沟通。就像，你知道，我在我的书中给出了这方面的脚本，因为我认为对某人发火真的很容易。实际上，当我们
we do that, it doesn't teach them anything other than go, oh, you made me feel bad. You know, oh, sorry. You know, like, that's not what I want, like in my relationships, for example. But I do want to kind of help people understand that actually doing that when I'm being present, like in a restaurant, that example is lovely, right? When I'm in a restaurant, it's about being able to communicate what feels right for you in that moment with a friend, with a partner, with your child, if they've got a smartphone or if you've got one, you know,
这样做时，除了让他们觉得“哦，你让我感觉很糟糕”之外，并不能教给他们任何东西。你知道，哦，抱歉。你知道，这并不是我在人际关系中想要的，例如。但我确实想帮助人们理解，实际上当我表现得专注时，比如在餐馆里，那个例子很好，对吧？当我在餐馆时，关键在于能够与朋友、伴侣、孩子沟通那一刻对你来说什么是合适的，如果他们有智能手机或者你有的话，你知道，
that open dialogue is so important, which might sound more like, oh, I'm a bit uncomfortable, your phone is here. It's like there's three of us at the table. Would you mind putting it away while we're eating? And maybe, if you're waiting for something important, could you put it on ring? Can we all accept that actually when our phones ring,
这种开放的对话非常重要，听起来可能更像是，“哦，我有点不舒服，你的手机在这里。就像桌子上有三个人一样。我们吃饭的时候你介意把它收起来吗？也许，如果你在等什么重要的事情，你能把它调成铃声吗？我们能都接受吗，实际上当我们的手机响时，
maybe somebody really wants to come, get to us? And that's important. So put it on ring. And if it rings and you're like, I really need to check its work. Of course I'm going to let you pick it up. And I'm not going to get offended. But a bit like you're saying, maybe if it's on the table, then there's three of us at the table. And I'm not going to be able to have an interaction with the third one because it's your phone, right?
也许真的有人想找我们？这很重要。所以把它调成铃声。如果它响了，你说，我真的需要检查一下工作。我当然会让你接听。我不会感到被冒犯。但就像你说的，也许如果它在桌子上，那么桌子上有三个人。我将无法与第三个人互动，因为那是你的手机，对吧？
That is a personal relationship. I'm not even a part of. And I think we need to have that conversation as well as set like good, healthy limits and boundaries in our homes with our family, but maybe also our visitors, you know, grandparents, friends you come to visit. I believe in like phone-free zones in your home. I think they're so important. And when they're clear for everyone, you're embedding something. There are certain areas in your home where your phone should just not show up. Shouldn't be there. Shouldn't exist. Doesn't need to. You're not going to sit in this place for hours. That's something really important
那是一种我甚至没有参与的个人关系。我认为我们需要进行那种对话，并在家里与家人，也许还有访客，比如祖父母、来访的朋友，设定良好、健康的限制和界限。我相信在家里设立无手机区域。我认为它们非常重要。当每个人都清楚这一点时，你就植入了一些东西。你家里有些区域手机根本不应该出现。不应该在那里。不应该存在。不需要。你不会在这个地方坐上几个小时。那是非常重要的事情
is going to happen and you're going to miss it. You might. miss it but you can always pick it up again a bit like you know people who knock on your front door so when i have dinner if there's a delivery unless i know exactly what it is we will not get up we don't get up we're just like they'll leave it on the porch like they'll leave it of course they will um it's just you don't pick it up you just leave it and it's a bit with our phones we could be like i'll pick up that message later it's not an urgent message i think it's a interesting that notifications are called alerts. When you alert something, it's important. Our phones are training us through their language, through their noises, through like the
将会发生，而你会错过它。你可能会错过它，但你总是可以再把它拿起来，就像敲你前门的人一样。所以当我吃晚餐时，如果有快递，除非我确切知道是什么，否则我们不会起身，我们不会起身，我们只是想，他们会把它留在门廊上，当然他们会。嗯，你只是不拿它，你只是把它留在那里。我们的手机也一样，我们可以想，我稍后再看那条消息，那不是紧急消息。我认为有趣的是通知被称为警报。当你警报某事时，它很重要。我们的手机正在通过它们的语言、声音、通过像
colours that they have to make them really important. But I think we can switch that off. Because once you're aware of the tricks, you can take control. Like a hundred percent, I believe that. That once you're like, oh yeah, that does happen to me. That's not helpful. You can switch you can switch off notifications for things that don't work for you you can put it on ring i'm always curious how many people switch off their phones ever completely unless they're on a plane you know it's one of my questions in my boat think about it but there's so many times where you could just switch it off do not a film at home not even in a cinema you do not have to have your phone on nothing's going to happen in two hours that like you need to know about switch it off and i think
它们拥有的颜色来训练我们，使它们变得非常重要。但我认为我们可以关掉它。因为一旦你意识到这些技巧，你就可以掌控。百分之百，我相信这一点。一旦你意识到，哦，是的，这确实发生在我身上。那没有帮助。你可以关掉对你不适用的通知，你可以把它调成铃声。我一直很好奇有多少人会完全关掉手机，除非他们在飞机上。你知道，这是我书中的问题之一，考虑一下。但有很多时候你完全可以关掉它。在家里看电影时，甚至在电影院里，你不需要开着手机，两个小时内不会发生什么你需要知道的事情。关掉它，我认为
when you need to put it on a ringtone, find a ringtone you like or a retro one or a song. Do you remember when we used to buy a phone ringtones? That's gone. I used to pay for mine. I want my phone to have this £2.60. Well, that's really expensive.
当你需要把它调成铃声时，找一个你喜欢的铃声，或者复古的，或者一首歌。你还记得我们过去买手机铃声的时候吗？那已经过去了。我过去常为我的铃声付费。我想要我的手机有这个2.60英镑的铃声。嗯，那真的很贵。
I'll go for this one. That's 99p. I mean, we don't do that anymore because nobody needs their phone to ring. I disagree with that. I think we need our phones to ring. I think we need to have them in a separate room. And they need to ring a little bit like a landline so that we're aware, oh, something's happening. And maybe I can pick up that message later. Oh, no, it's ringing continuously. Something important is going on.
我会选这个。那是99便士。我的意思是，我们不再那样做了，因为没有人需要他们的手机响。我不同意这一点。我认为我们需要手机响。我认为我们需要把它们放在单独的房间里。它们需要像座机一样响一点，这样我们就会意识到，哦，有事情发生了。也许我可以稍后再看那条消息。哦，不，它一直在响。有重要的事情正在发生。
That is very different to checking, like mindlessly checking. Oh, no, it's just the weather. Oh, no, it's the news. Oh, no. I just don't think that's helpful. And that's also impacting our nervous system because we're overstimulated by the buzzing all the time. That's so important. And I love the idea of thinking about it as a third person and actually I'm just back from holiday and I kept my phone mainly in the safe when I was away and because I just wanted to just obviously be present but also read more and you know play in the pool and do all of those things but yeah I love that idea and if I still had my ringed home that I'd paid money for I would be having the Justin Timberlake hook of it feels like something's heating up get with you get it back Marianne get it back on
这与检查，比如无意识地检查，是非常不同的。哦，不，只是天气。哦，不，是新闻。哦，不。我只是认为那没有帮助。而且这也影响了我们的神经系统，因为我们一直被嗡嗡声过度刺激。这太重要了。我喜欢把它当作第三个人来思考的想法，实际上我刚从度假回来，我离开时主要把手机放在保险箱里，因为我只是想显然保持专注，但也多读书，你知道，在游泳池里玩，做所有那些事情。但是的，我喜欢那个想法，如果我还有我花钱买的铃声，我会放贾斯汀·汀布莱克的那个片段，感觉有什么东西在升温，和你在一起，拿回来，玛丽安，把它拿回来，开着
I love it. That's what would be happening. So I've still got mine. So it's still ringing. What's it called? Oh my God, I have to look it up now because I want to tell you. It's a ring tone that we all got obsessed by when we went on a ski trip in Austria. Oh, oh no, it's on the tip of my tank.
我喜欢它。那就会发生。所以我还有我的。所以它还在响。它叫什么？哦，天哪，我现在必须查一下，因为我想告诉你。这是一个我们在奥地利滑雪旅行时大家都着迷的铃声。哦，哦不，它就在我的舌尖上。
Now I'm going to have to find it. But it's still there, so I've started to use it a bit more, but now I can't remember. Barbara Streisand. but it brings me such happy feelings I know what you mean oh you'll have to just listen it's called Barbara Streisor yeah that one
现在我得把它找出来。但它还在那里，所以我开始更多地使用它，但现在我不记得了。芭芭拉·史翠珊。但它带给我如此快乐的感觉，我知道你的意思，哦，你只需要听一下，它叫芭芭拉·史翠珊，是的，那一个
yeah I know what you mean it gives me such joy when I hear it like anywhere because it reminds me of that insane ski holiday with like there was 24 of us it was insane it was lovely and it was on every night it was like the song of the moment
是的，我知道你的意思，无论在哪里听到它，它都给我带来如此多的快乐，因为它让我想起那个疯狂的滑雪假期，有24个人，太疯狂了，太可爱了，它每天晚上都在响，就像那一刻的歌
But that's my ringtone, so I still have it. But I hadn't used it for ages. And then, you know, I think the process of writing my book, I wrote it for parents, but I definitely wrote it for me too because I think some of the questions I was considering or being asked or thinking about, I was like, these apply to me. And I can't tell people to do something that I'm not willing to do for myself in my home with my family. So so much of this book is for me, too. And one of the things I have done, for sure.
但那是我的铃声，所以我还有它。但我很久没用了。然后，你知道，我认为写书的过程，我是为父母写的，但我绝对也是为我自己写的，因为我认为我正在考虑、被问到或思考的一些问题，我想，这些也适用于我。我不能告诉人们做一些我不愿意在家里和家人一起做的事情。所以这本书的很多内容也是为我写的。而且我确实做了一件事，肯定的。
I mean, it's got a tick on Barberus Wright. That's what I found. I guess it's there. You know, I put my phone on ring. I do all these things I talk about. They are possible to do. I haven't asked for massive changes. And I think it's about picking and choosing the things you want to try out.
我的意思是，它在芭芭拉·史翠珊上打了个勾。这就是我发现的。我想它就在那里。你知道，我把手机调成铃声。我做了我谈到的所有这些事情。它们是可能做到的。我没有要求巨大的改变。我认为关键在于挑选你想尝试的事情。
I always say with habits, like, you need to start teeny tiny and hold it and be really consistent. and then when it starts to feel really natural and comfortable and you're like, don't even think about it anymore, then you can introduce something else. You don't have to introduce and shouldn't introduce like 20 changes at once because it's going, it's not going to work. Teeny tiny tweaks can make such a difference like putting your phone in a different room, just as I said, you know, mealtimes or in those phone-free zones in your house. Oh, no, my phone's not allowed in this room, so I'll put it on ring and it's on a shelf and, you know, just that tiny thing. can suddenly go, oh my God, there's so much space in my house and it's so quiet and I feel so much
我总是说关于习惯，你需要从极小的事情开始，坚持住，并且非常一致。然后当它开始感觉非常自然和舒适，你不再去想它时，你就可以引入别的东西。你不必也不应该一次引入20个改变，因为这不会奏效。极小的调整可以带来很大的不同，比如把手机放在不同的房间，就像我说的，你知道，用餐时间或在你家里的那些无手机区域。哦，不，我的手机不允许在这个房间里，所以我把它调成铃声，放在架子上，你知道，仅仅是那件小事，突然间就会觉得，哦天哪，我的房子里有这么多空间，而且非常安静，我感觉非常
calmer. And I didn't realize that carrying my phone and was actually overstimulating me. But it is. It is like a toddler interrupting you every few minutes. And if you've got a toddler, it's an extra one. Yeah. My phone even likes to be present when I'm brushing my teeth. So I've got an oral B toothbrush that guides you. It's very handy, very, you know. But yeah, it likes to be in the bathroom with me. And so, yeah, this is really going to make me think about my phone-free zones. So I have that too, but I don't take it with me. I don't use it anymore.
平静。我没有意识到带着手机实际上在过度刺激我。但确实如此。它就像一个每隔几分钟就打断你的蹒跚学步的孩子。如果你有一个蹒跚学步的孩子，那就是多了一个。是的。我刷牙时我的手机甚至喜欢在场。所以我有一个欧乐B牙刷来指导你。它非常方便，非常，你知道。但是的，它喜欢和我一起在浴室里。所以，是的，这真的会让我思考我的无手机区域。所以我也有那个，但我不再带着它了。我不再使用它了。
I think it's great for learning that will all be up. Learning to brush your teeth well for the right amount of time. I still use it because when I don't, I do get a bit lazier and I will talk or multitask. It actually keeps me mindful when I'm brushing my teeth that I don't do something. else yeah got a smile to maintain but you know that my phone helps me be mindful to do this one do it that's not interrupting disrupting but don't sit and scroll on the toilet with it like that's that's a different thing but also well i don't know i think some people might be like on a toilet i like to be distracted you know i can't read on a toilet but i know people who like to read on a toilet
我认为它对于学习刷牙非常好。学习在正确的时间内刷好牙。我仍然使用它，因为当我不用它时，我确实会变得有点懒，我会说话或多任务处理。它实际上让我刷牙时保持专注，我不会做别的事情。是的，有一个微笑要保持，但你知道我的手机帮助我保持专注来做这件事，做它，那不是打断，干扰，但不要坐在马桶上刷手机，那是另一回事，但也，嗯，我不知道，我认为有些人可能像在马桶上我喜欢分心，你知道，我不能在马桶上读书，但我认识喜欢在马桶上读书的人
if that's you i would say there's nothing wrong with it that's the thing with the smartphone conversation feels like some things are bad and some things are good. And I'm like, but it's different for everyone. It's unique. And I think you need to find your balance, especially if you've got kids. You need to find your family balance. What works for you? If that works for you with your teeth, keep doing it. It, you know, fact, we listen to Hey Dougie, the toothbrush song with my kids every night. So the phone also comes with us with the toothbrushing. But we don't look at it, but we use it because it's so handy the song is on our phone we play it we know what two minutes sounds like they both love the song great why would i stop doing that it's not disrupting anything
如果你是那样的人，我会说这没什么错，这就是智能手机对话的问题，感觉有些事情是坏的，有些事情是好的。而我心想，但这对每个人都不同。它是独特的。我认为你需要找到你的平衡，特别是如果你有孩子的话。你需要找到你的家庭平衡。什么对你有效？如果这对你的牙齿有效，继续做。它，你知道，事实上，我们每天晚上和我的孩子们听Hey Dougie，刷牙歌。所以手机也和牙刷一起跟着我们。但我们不看它，但我们使用它，因为它太方便了，歌在我们的手机上，我们播放它，我们知道两分钟听起来是什么样的，他们两个都喜欢这首歌，太棒了，我为什么要停止这样做？它没有干扰任何事情
it's facilitating something but maybe like i was saying maybe you don't need it on you don't need to scroll while you're watching a film are you watching a film or are you scrolling like make a decision you know that's the difference like find your moments this is going to stay with me and I'm going to get your book as soon as it's available. And I'm aware that by the time this is released, it should be available. Tell us, tell us when it's published, tell us where we can get it. And just remind us what it's called Dr. Marta. So it's called The Smart Phone Solution, When and How to Give Your Child a Phone,
它在促进某事，但也许就像我说的，也许你不需要它在你身上，你不需要在看电影时刷手机，你是在看电影还是在刷手机？做一个决定，你知道，这就是区别，找到你的时刻，这将伴随我，我一有书就会买你的书。我知道到这发布时，它应该已经上市了。告诉我们，告诉我们它什么时候出版，告诉我们可以在哪里买到。并提醒我们它叫什么，玛塔博士。所以它叫《智能手机解决方案，何时以及如何给你的孩子一部手机》，
and it's out on the 28th of August in all good bookshops. Your Waterstones will have copies of it. And if you have a local bookshop, which I always like to promote and kind of tell people about, you can go in and if they don't have a copy they can order it in for you i really believe in shopping small and you know supporting books and authors um people often ask me like where would you prefer us to buy your book and i'm like honestly your local bookshop would it pleases me when local bookshops kind of get that income i think it's lovely but you know all the waterstones will have it so that's somewhere i would say and of course you can also get it online um
它将于8月28日在所有好的书店上市。你的Waterstones书店会有副本。如果你有当地的书店，我总是喜欢推广并告诉人们，你可以进去，如果他们没有副本，他们可以为你订购。我真的相信小额购物，你知道，支持书籍和作者。人们经常问我，你更希望我们在哪里买你的书，我说老实说，你的当地书店，当当地书店得到那种收入时，我很高兴，我认为这很可爱。但你知道，所有的Waterstones都会有它，所以那是我会说的地方，当然你也可以在线购买，嗯
So it should be in most places, I think. Amazing. And you're also on social media. I think that Instagram is the best place to follow you. If anyone's listening to this as a podcast, Dr. Marta is spelled Martha, so M-A-R-T-H-A. So you're on Instagram as Dr. Marta. Psychologist. Ah, right. Dr. Marta psychologist.
所以它应该在大多数地方，我想。太棒了。你也在社交媒体上。我认为Instagram是关注你的最佳地点。如果有人在播客上听这个，玛塔博士的拼写是Martha，所以M-A-R-T-H-A。所以你在Instagram上是Dr. Marta。心理学家。啊，对了。Dr. Marta心理学家。
The reason being I'm not a medical doctor, and I'm very proud. of being a psychologist. That's my career. There's nothing wrong with it. So I, yeah, if I just call myself Dr. Marta, I always worries that people would think I was a medical doctor and I am not. So I am Dr. Marta, Martha, psychologist. Thank you for the clarification. It's been wonderful chatting with you and I hope that the book really gets digested and implemented because I think something needs to change, doesn't it? And yeah, I can't wait to, I can't wait to read it. well done to you in advance. Thank you.
原因是我不是医学博士，我非常自豪能成为一名心理学家。那是我的职业。这没什么错。所以我，是的，如果我只称自己为玛塔博士，我总是担心人们会认为我是医学博士，而我不是。所以我叫Dr. Marta，Martha，心理学家。谢谢你的澄清。和你聊天真是太棒了，我希望这本书真的能被消化和实施，因为我认为有些事情需要改变，不是吗？是的，我迫不及待地想，我迫不及待地想读它。做得好，提前祝贺你。谢谢。
And to anyone who's interested in learning more about Dr. Marta and her career, we've got another episode coming up to celebrate our 200 episode series where you can learn more about how Dr. Marta became the psychologist she is before us. So thank you for your time, Dr. Marta, and we will see you again very soon. See you, see. Thank you so much for Dr. Marta de Roscajado's time. What a wonderful episode. Please do let me know in the comments.
对于任何有兴趣了解更多关于玛塔博士和她的职业生涯的人，我们还有另一集即将推出，以庆祝我们的200集系列，在那里你可以了解更多关于玛塔博士在我们之前是如何成为她现在的心理学家的。所以谢谢你的时间，玛塔博士，我们很快会再见到你。再见，再见。非常感谢玛塔·德·罗斯卡哈多博士的时间。多么精彩的一集。请在评论中告诉我
this has resonated with you. Has it set any ideas about how you might think about introducing phone time or maybe even going into, you know, drawing up more boundary use of phone and screen time for your children or children in your family or even children you might be working with if you're in a children and young people's service such as cams. I'm doing this episode on a different day than when I recorded with Dr. Marta and I'm wearing the same top so you didn't notice. Did you notice? Could you tell my hair was slightly different? But yeah, I have really found that it's resonated with me and made me think about being more intentional and more mindful with my phone use. So yeah, the evening that I did it, I decided
这是否引起了你的共鸣。它是否引发了关于你可能如何考虑引入手机时间，或者甚至进入，你知道，为你的孩子或你家庭中的孩子，甚至如果你在儿童和年轻人服务机构（如CAMS）工作，你可能正在工作的孩子，制定更多关于手机和屏幕时间使用的界限的想法。我是在与玛塔博士录制的那天之后的一天做这一集的，我穿着同样的衣服，所以你没有注意到。你注意到了吗？你能看出我的头发稍微不同吗？但是的，我确实发现它引起了我的共鸣，让我思考在手机使用上更加有意识和更加专注。所以是的，我做的那天晚上，我决定
actually, when I'm watching TV with my husband, I don't use my phone anyway, but I'm going to keep it in a separate room. And then when he kind of goes up to use the bathroom and stuff in the evening. I would often sit and scroll and check what I'd missed on WhatsApp, but you know, I haven't. I haven't done it. It can wait. It can wait. I can get to it in the morning. So yeah, do let me know in the comments what you are having as your take home messages from this episode. There will be a link in the description and in the show notes for you to grab a copy of Dr. Marta's book, The Smartphone Solution. Please, if you do buy it and you enjoy it, please do leave Marta a review because it really does help people to demonstrate that their book is well
实际上，当我和丈夫看电视时，我反正不用手机，但我会把它放在单独的房间里。然后当他晚上上楼去洗手间之类的东西时。我经常会坐着刷手机，检查我在WhatsApp上错过了什么，但你知道，我没有。我没有那样做。它可以等。它可以等。我可以在早上处理它。所以是的，请在评论中告诉我你从这一集中得到的带回家的信息。描述和节目说明中会有一个链接，供你获取玛塔博士的书《智能手机解决方案》的副本。请，如果你买了它并且喜欢它，请务必给玛塔留下评论，因为它确实帮助人们证明他们的书是
worth reading. And books that are well reviewed are shown higher up listings by booksellers. So it really does help them and the author too. Psychologist Paskets with Dr. Mary and Trent. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I. did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most
非常值得一读的。而且评论好的书会被书商显示在列表的更高位置。所以它确实帮助了他们，也帮助了作者。心理学家播客，玛丽安·特伦特博士。嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书来帮助自己为我的第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我买了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程是如此深刻，它给了我很多关于我自己的旅程和技能的反思。它也有助于把事情放在正确的角度，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。我认为最
unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
意想不到的快乐，然而，是每个人旅程的鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是太高兴了。我几乎不情愿结束。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。